[Musique]
bienvenue au paradis tropical de Beauval
le dôme équatorial est un lieu
extraordinaire qui accueille une grande
variété d'espèces la preuve je suis là
voilà il y a des Kamini des anacondas
des lamantins des loutres géantes et
même des varans de Komodo connaissez le
varan de Komodo hein si c'est l'animal
qui te mord il te met un poison après il
te suit la tant que tu meurs pour te
manger il attend là tranquille
tu es mort ou pas encore non tu me dis
que c'est bon je t'attends ici les
animaux sont aussi terrifiants que
terrifiants Rodolphe Delort directeur du
zoo m'attend afin de m'expliquer
pourquoi Beauval est un lieu de
conservation des espèces et des
ressources naturelles allez c'est parti
pour l'aventure
sauvage
le pont bouge
ça y est Rodolphe bonjour Quelle
aventure et ça se mérite Beauvais
ici exactement 2 millions d'aventuriers
cette année vont visiter bon vague
Roudolphe puis un paradoxe de
préservation parce que même si tu aimes
et tu prends que la vie sauvage doit
rester sauvage il faut bien des gens
comme toi pour la préserver cette vie
sauvage bien évidemment et à vie doit
rester sauvage au maximum mais parc
zoologiques sont indispensables à
conservation des espèces et nous sommes
aussi des lieux de sensibilisation nous
sommes en quelque sorte le premier
voyage vers la vie sauvage pour les
enfants
urbains souvent des connectés de la
biodiversité il y a combien d'espèces à
peu près ici aux zoo de Beauval à peu
près 900 espèces 35000 animaux en
comptant tous les poissons des espèces
très menacées mais aussi assez bien
disparition moins menacé ou pas menacé
du tout il faut tout mais même avec des
espèces qui ne sont pas menacées on peut
sensibiliser le public à la conservation
et malheureusement à terme toute la vie
sauvage risque de devenir menacé à cause
de l'explosion démographique notamment
humaine sache que dans tous les cas sera
toujours compter sur moi Kamini
l'aventurier à tout à l'heure
[Musique]
tortue dangereuse
vite expert en sécurité animale
vous avez vu ça un phoque mais non je
suis un lamantin
Rodolphe derrière ce n'est pas le varan
ou dragon de Komodo exactement ça
rappelle mes aventures en Afrique non il
y en a pas en Afrique
il vient d'où celui-là alors va rendre
commodo il vient des Komodo
il te mord tu as un poison dedans il te
suit pendant une heure j'attends
j'attends que tu meurs et attends que tu
meurs et que tu sois décomposé en plus
d'accord
le Komodo malgré c'est super pouvoir
c'est une espèce en voie de disparition
et c'est à protéger aussi c'est
extrêmement menacé c'est un animal très
très ancien qui est important de
protéger donc nous conservons et nous
finançons aussi des problèmes de
conservation et à bas directement sur
place à commando